we wouldn't know about it if it were not
for jeremy lafredo who works for rebel
news he joins us tonight jeremy thanks
so much for coming on this one stories
it's kind of hard to believe they're
going after an amish
farmer
who are they exactly
we have um the u.s marshals service
recently raided amos miller's um organic
and holistic farm um demanding he ceased
operations and they charged him as you
said with 300 000
of fines economically crippling the man
and what's happening is you have
um the armed federal agents are
demanding he stop food production
because of the meat and
you have him saying well you know what i
want to keep farming so you have this
back and forth between the giant empire
of the us federal government and this
tiny little farm in birdingham
pennsylvania
so they went after gems
organic farmers and churches
so maybe they're against anything that's
wholesome and edifying that makes you
stronger and healthier and in favor of
everything that diminishes you and makes
you more dependent i'm just sensing a
theme here do you see this
yeah and another thing the community
says is that they're coming after amos
to set an example they're coming after
an independent successful farmer who
takes out the government middlemen and
provides food directly to his community
and his people now by taking out the
middleman by taking out the government
you're taking power away and taking
leverage away from the government and
putting that power and leverage in the
hands of the community and the farmers
and the people and another thing i'll
add is amos's farm doesn't use any
gasoline or any fertilizer now as you
know these commodities have become very
expensive because of biden's policies in
regards to the war in ukraine and russia
so amos has completely
eliminated eliminated any risk coming
from the international or domestic
politics of the biden administration and
you know they're coming after him for it
maybe if he promises to put more
chemicals in the milk that turn kids
trans they'll lay off did any of the
federal marshals decline to raid an
amish organic farm on principal or do
they all just go along with this do you
know
all i know is that um
many federal agents did not um decline
to go and did go along with it and
raided the farm and took inventory of
amos's um farm to make sure that he
doesn't sell or produce any more meat
you know i we're for law enforcement
broadly speaking but there's such a
thing as conscience okay and they should
not have gone along with this when they
tell you to raid an organic amish farm
that's when you bow out okay i would say
and jeremy i appreciate your story that
you did it's shocking to believe it's
real but it is
we're thankful that you came
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight